[Aplausos]
después de todos estos años creo que
estoy totalmente convencido que las
personas que hicieron y metieron este
amor tan grande por la naturaleza ha
sido mi familia definitivamente yo
recuerdo que desde que éramos pequeños
mis papás cogían a mí ya mi hermana el
perro y el gato en el carro en el bus en
donde sea y salíamos fuera de quito
cualquier lugar con estar fuera de la
ciudad en el campo con naturaleza que
era lo que nos hacía sentir súper bien
tal vez esto fue también una de las
cosas que hizo que después en la
universidad y empieza a estudiar
biología y es interesante porque a lo
largo de todo el día los ecuatorianos
nos dicen claro ecuador es el país más
diverso el más increíble con tantos
ecosistemas pero es realmente cuando
ustedes empiezan a viajar lo que se dan
cuenta que si realmente es así es mucho
más de lo que lo dice entonces les voy a
dar por los próximos minutos una pequeña
introducción a través del lente de mi
cámara fotográfica de cómo empecé a
descubrir ecuador y sus maravillas
naturales y cómo empezó el inicio de
todos estos proyectos que ahora
manejamos entonces primera salida de
campo en la universidad 18 años en
biología la amazonía
nacional yasuní literalmente el lugar
más biodiverso de la tierra casa de
muchísimas especies de animales por
ejemplo la nutria gigante este animal
puede llegar a medir hasta 2 metros de
largo es la más grande del mundo y come
hasta 7 libras de pescado por día es por
eso que es uno de los indicadores de
calidad del agua en la amazonía pero
bueno no todos son predadores allá abajo
sino también tenemos unos animales súper
interesantes y tal vez super tiernos
como todos ustedes conocen como los
perezosos de tres dedos en este caso un
símbolo completo de la amazonía aunque
realmente la verdadera diversidad del
país está oculto en las pequeñas formas
anfibios reptiles insectos estos grupos
que son poco estudiados o conocidos por
todos nosotros pero bueno después de
subir de la amazonía tenemos a nuestros
increíbles andy es que ustedes saben es
la cadena montañosa más larga del mundo
que atraviesa toda sudamérica en estos
andes los quiteños y los ecuatorianos
hemos aprendido a vivir con los volcanes
y nos hemos dado cuenta que siempre no
están no se ven siempre ha sido bonitos
como en la foto siento muchas veces
entran en proceso de erupción lo cual
nos tiene a todas
la población atentos en movimiento y
darnos en estar super flexibles a todos
los cambios en este ecosistema en esta
gigantesca cadena de montañas tenemos
algunos animales que también se han
adaptado a esta área por ejemplo no sé
si ustedes conocen este pájaro es el
colibrí pico espada y es el único ave en
el planeta que su pico es más grande que
su cuerpo y por qué es esto porque se
alimenta específicamente de una flor que
nosotros conocemos aquí como floripondio
que es el mismo forma de su pico y sólo
él se puede poder polinizar y
alimentarse de aquí pero volviendo al
mundo pequeño y realmente
donde creo que está toda esa grandiosa
diversidad alguna vez ustedes han visto
una rana sí imagínense tenemos como 10
de estas en el ecuador son como de este
tamaño y cada una tiene su propio diseño
de uñas
ok ustedes me dicen que no les gusta el
anaranjado tal vez podemos encontrarlas
en blanco o si es que no les gusta en
blanco tal vez en amarillo estas formas
entonces los andes' genera que estas
especies puedan cada uno de ellos
adaptarse a estos lugares y crear
cientos de especies por él es una de las
razones en la riqueza de nuestra
diversidad pero bueno al otro lado de
los andes en la parte norte nuestra
provincia verde de esmeraldas
encontramos el bosque tropical del choco
que es muy similar a la amazonía pero al
otro lado de los andes es un bosque
lluvioso de igual manera y tenemos
algunas especies en el área que por lo
menos asumo que ustedes la conocen por
ejemplo el oso de anteojos
el oso andino el único oso que tenemos
en sudamérica y que lastimosamente cada
vez está más amenazado por la
deforestación pero volviendo al mundo
macro tenemos las ranas de cristal por
ejemplo asumo que ustedes han oído son
estas pequeñas ranitas que tienen toda
la parte ventral transparente entonces
ustedes
se acercan pueden ver el corazón
latiendo todos sus intestinos y digamos
que en esta foto es particularmente una
hembra y los puntos verdes que ustedes
vengan son sus huevos entonces es algo
espectacular que la primera vez que ven
no lo pueden creer de verdad als al sur
del chaco tenemos nuestro bosque seco
que la mayoría está cubierto por estos
hermosos árboles que me fascinan que se
llaman selvas yo les llamo los bávaros
ecuatorianos son gigantes con el tronco
enorme pero como es un bosque seco casi
todo el año pierden sus hojas y hacen
fotosíntesis por el tallo entonces al
frente como este el bosque seco tenemos
el océano pacífico donde cada año
justamente en esta época de junio a
septiembre tenemos unos gigantes
visitantes que nos vienen desde la
antártida principalmente para
reproducirse buscando aguas más cálidas
menos profundas y para dar a luz a sus
pequeños como son las ballenas jorobadas
así que si quieren chance vayan a puerto
lópez es el mejor lugar
pero el ecuador continental no es sólo
justamente lo que tenemos aquí en el
continente sino al frente tenemos las
famosas islas galápagos
todos nosotros conocemos y las islas
galápagos tienen un origen volcánico o
sea estas fotos de la erupción del 2015
en el volcán wolf en la parte norte de
isabela pero sin ir muy lejos las
últimas semanas hemos tenido actividad
volcánica igual en dos de los diferentes
volcanes lo cual también a estas islas
separadas totalmente el continente
tienen una adaptación diferentes
especies que viven en esta área este es
el único cormorán en el mundo que no
puede volar perdió totalmente la
capacidad de vuelo por falta de
predadores y porque se alimenta 100% de
los peces
entonces es un increíble nadador el gato
que ustedes es muy gracioso verlos salir
después de que pesca porque como no
tienen sus pobres alitas éstas se cagan
dice en el sol y se ve muy gracioso
tenemos también otra especie súper
importante que son las tortugas gigantes
galápagos junto con seychelles son los
únicos lugares en el planeta donde
tienen estos gigantes lastimosamente
hace 300 años llegaron casi a la
extinción gracias a todos los piratas
son navegantes que pasaban por ahí en
ese entonces no había refrigeradoras
entonces querían encoger carne fresca
estos animales a bordo podían estar
hasta 6 meses sin comer o tomar agua por
suerte ahora están protegidos por el
parque nacional
del ambiente pero en todo este viaje
durante los últimos años me dado cuenta
que lastimosamente ecuador no es solo
líder en esta diversidad sino también
ocupamos en el primer lugar en las
categorías de amenazas y qué es lo que
amenaza tanto a nuestra diversidad
diferentes cosas la deforestación por
ejemplo ecuador pese que es tan pequeño
junto con colombia y brasil lideramos la
deforestación las tasas de deforestación
es en sudamérica cada año perdemos
200.000 hectáreas de bosque primario lo
cual algunos científicos estiman que
para el 2030 2050 no vamos a tener más
cobertura digital primaria entonces es
algo súper deprimente de verdad otra
cosa es los monocultivos por ejemplo la
palma africana es un problema que no
sólo este ecuador sino todos los bosques
tropicales en el mundo y es básicamente
para producir diferentes textiles
maquillajes o alimentos que nosotros
mismos podemos empezar a ser parte de
esta solución y trato de hacer las
compras revisando que los productos no
contengan aceite de palma otro gran
problema es el tráfico ilegal de fauna
sacar animales silvestres para tenerlos
en la casa de mascotas que normalmente
después
y mueren por darles de comer solo arroz
o pan entonces realmente no es algo que
no se justifica actividades extractivas
tanto en la amazonía tenemos la
actividad petrolera y en la parte sur
del ecuador la explotación minera a
cielo abierto principalmente que es un
impacto super grande para el país y algo
que nosotros también estamos
involucrados en el día a día por ejemplo
es la contaminación justa el 2018 es el
año mundial de la lucha para la
reducción del plástico lo cual es algo
que nosotros podemos empezar a
contribuir directamente desde hoy el
cambio climático que es más o menos algo
que se traduce en un conjunto de todos
los detalles que le dije anteriores les
dije anteriormente pero básicamente
lugares como ecuador que no tenemos
todas las estaciones hace que nuestras
ver nuestras épocas secas sean más
largas nuestras lluvias sean más fuertes
y producen sequías y diferentes
problemas de los animales estas fotos en
la isla
una en la sequía del 2011 una de las más
fuertes que ha tenido esta zona que seco
todos los lagos hicieron que todos los
animales básicamente se mueran de la
zona entonces con todo este contraste de
increíble diversidad y también todas las
amenazas y hoy junto a un mar
grupo de colegas decidimos dedicarnos al
estudio y conservación de la
biodiversidad por el resto de nuestras
vidas entonces lo que deseamos hacer
formamos un gran equipo y fondant
fundamos tropical harvey y es esta
iniciativa
hairpin significa buscar anfibios y
reptiles en el campo que es nuestro
grupo favorito en los que nos gusta
investigar y lo que hacemos es como todo
equipo de investigación escribir libros
artículos científicos guías de campo
hacer expediciones científicas para
buscar especies nuevas pero de verdad
quisimos ir un poquito más allá nos
dimos cuenta tras estudiar biología que
normalmente hay una desconexión muy
grande entre la ciencia per se y el
mundo en general la ciencia roja
normalmente datos que son difíciles de
asimilar para la mayoría de personas que
no tienen entrenamiento en ciencia y
decidimos usar que consta la fotografía
el vídeo y diferentes herramientas
gráficas porque los seres humanos somos
personas somos seres totalmente gráficos
entonces una foto un vídeo puede llegar
a conmover me y de una otra manera
invitarme a mí a actuar entonces la
fotografía combinada con el ecoturismo
que nuestros proyectos puede llegar a la
mayor cantidad de personas no solo en
ecuador sino en el mundo y a la vez esto
nos da un dinero para poder financiar a
nosotros mismos nuestros propios
proyectos todos los proyectos que les
había comentado anteriormente entonces
este rato les voy a dar una pequeña
ejemplo de dos proyectos en los que
hemos colaborado uno de ellos fue en los
manglares de la costa por ejemplo otro
de los ecosistemas importantes acá es
súper diverso y también hay gente que
con con escasos recursos que viven en
esta zona entonces una manera muy fácil
y rápida de obtener recursos es cortar
todo el manglar sembrar una camaronera y
te da un ingreso rápido digamos pero qué
pasa que esta zona también es súper alta
en tsunamis entonces lo que pasa es que
cuando viene un tsunami no hay manglares
que es una barrera natural y básicamente
se lleva a toda la población entonces en
un esfuerzo conjunto y una colaboración
con conservación internacional lo que
hicimos es trabajar con una comunidad
del guayas que se llama 6 de junio que
aprendieron a vivir del manglar usando
sus productos del manglar en este caso
los cangrejos nos fuimos un día con
ellos todo
desde que se levantan hasta que se
acuestan en su día de trabajo el
espectacular vélez a la gente metiéndose
por completo en el lodo para sacar los
cangrejos regresaban era un festín que
todos lavando sus carritos y listos para
llevarlos a vender y las mujeres también
era algo esto era una parte de las que
más me gustó porque además de preparar
los medios platos más exquisitos de
cangrejo en toda la parte de guayas lo
que hacen es capacitan a diferentes
restaurantes para que se promueva el
consumo sustentable de cangrejos pero
también lideran los programas de
reforestación de mangle y finalmente
ellos también conocen las especies que
están en la zona para que pues se puede
hacer un ecoturismo a nivel nacional e
internacional con aves de la que viven
los manglares y entonces claro ya cuando
todo empieza a funcionar en conjunto los
gobiernos locales también se involucran
y hacen que desde los niños las
generaciones nuevas se den cuenta de la
importancia de este ecosistema entonces
claro como en todo estudio tiene que ser
publicado empezamos a sacar diferentes
artículos que ahora se están usando como
modelos a nivel
donde se está trabajando con manglar
para que la gente en vez de explotar
este ecosistema se dedique a tratar de
vivir con ellos de una manera más
sustentable no solo para la naturaleza
sino también para las personas que son
los actores directos de la naturaleza y
el segundo proyecto que tengo es en el
choco por ahora este ecosistema que les
decía el choco ecuatoriano que junto con
madagascar son los ecosistemas más
amenazados del mundo hablando de bosques
tropicales es es una cosa realmente
deprimente porque menos del 5% de la
cobertura original del choco se ha ido
por completo
entonces eso quiere decir que es un área
tan diversa con tantas plantas
anfibios reptiles aves
entonces lo que nosotros empezamos a
hacer es atacar en diferentes fuertes
primero en la educación
junto a mi equipo
normalmente publicamos diferentes libros
o material didáctico que está libre en
nuestra página web pero también tratamos
de llegar a gobiernos locales para que
se vaya a las escuelas y que pueda se
pueda capacitar a la gente que vive en
la zona literal diferentes artículos que
se publican a nivel nacional o
internacional para generar conciencia
sobre el área a proteger estamos
trabajando en un libro formato confite y
bold book que está va a estar en inglés
y en español que va a ser distribuido
aquí a nivel nacional y también en el
extranjero para levantar más
expectativas sobre el área y también
creamos una ong conjunto a una fundación
ecuatoriana llamada la fundación
jocotoco y una compañía de diseño en
eeuu
con nuestro socio james moore y creamos
esta iniciativa crear safe de choco que
lo que hace es justamente tratar de
reunir fondos y trabajo en general a
nivel internacional para proteger este
ecosistema uno de los ejemplos super
puntuales es que a veces nosotros
organizamos diferentes subastas por
ejemplo ésta fue nueva york el año
pasado entonces muchos artistas
todo grafos pintores diferentes artistas
donaron sus obras vendimos las obras y
recaudamos casi 12 mil dólares que
fueron al proyecto para invertir en
nuevas en comprar nuevas tierras en
áreas protegidas del choco y un ejemplo
que está súper fresquito en una
investigación liderada por mi socio
alejandro arteaga como el que creamos
tropical harvey describimos estas 59
especies de serpientes que encontramos
en el ecuador pero lo que hicimos en vez
de ponerle el nombre como normalmente se
hace investigación
decidimos subastar el nombre para esta
subasta la hicimos en nueva york' y
entonces personas normales como un
evento como este la gente quería que su
nombre esté en la serpiente porque el
nombre queda literal para siempre y de
este evento logramos recaudar 65 65 mil
dólares aproximadamente que nos sirvió
para comprar 72 hectáreas de bosque
protect de bosque primario completamente
o sea que no tenía ninguna protección y
financiar más salidas de campo para
encontrar nuevas especies como este
entonces es una forma de tratar de hacer
una como ciencia ciudadana
hacer que la ciencia sea
e involucrada con la gente y que la
gente se empodere de esto y tome acción
por eso también es importante informar a
las personas con charlas aquí a nivel
nacional internacional o poner toda
nuestra biodiversidad al acceso de la
gente entonces este por ejemplo fue una
exposición que hicimos junto con el
municipio de quito en el bulevar de las
naciones unidas y era súper genial ver a
la gente cómo interactúa con las
imágenes trataba de leer y decir oye
donde sea esto donde vive y es la única
manera que la gente cuando conozca pueda
proteger algo y yo creo que desde ahora
es tiempo para empezar a poner la
semillita para el futuro que realmente
es las nuevas generaciones y lo que lo
que hicimos el año pasado junto a mi
socia karim ait nerd que es de eeuu y
fue formada oficialmente como la editora
de national geographic kids week que
creamos una iniciativa que se llama keep
conservation photography workshop que es
traer menores de edad de todo el mundo
involucrarlos en estas problemáticas
hacemos diferentes talleres en países
diversos con ecuador- namibia madagascar
etcétera y lo que
haces traer a estos menores de edad con
un equipo de científicos para que
documenten el trabajo que ellos hacen
cada día para proteger nuestra
diversidad pero no solo con científicos
sino también con comunidades indígenas
porque normalmente es una interacción de
ciencia de educación entonces es una
manera de también dar un paso para las
nuevas generaciones entonces realmente
la ciencia tiene que ser 100% aburrida o
inalcanzable para las personas no
totalmente lo contrario más bien las
personas tienen que ser activistas de
esta ciencia y la mejor manera de hacer
que la gente conozca lo que tiene en su
país desde mi punto de vista es usando
los medios gráficos para llegar a la
mayor cantidad de personas
muchas gracias a mi equipo ya todos
ustedes por la atención
[Aplausos]